We can get started.
And this morning will be a
slightly different style of
lecture.
You'll notice that you don't
have handouts,
and that wasn't an oversight.
It was actually because you
won't need them this morning.
What we're going to be doing is
something of an experiment,
which is that it seemed to me
that it was useful,
when you were reading various
historical works,
that sometimes the author of
one of them should explain and
discuss with you how they came
to be as they are.
So, that was one of the reasons
that I put my own book,
this one, on Naples,
on the reading list.
And I thought this morning I'd
try the experiment of a
different kind of lecture,
where I talk to you about how
it came to be the work that it
is.
We're moving on now from the
material on the Paris School and
on plague and smallpox,
to our next major epidemic
disease,
which was the great feared
disease of the nineteenth
century,
which was Asiatic cholera,
which hit Europe--
it wasn't an endemic
disease--it hit Europe for the
first time around 1830,
and returned in a series of
pandemics in various waves.
And normally the official
historiography has it that about
the last epidemic in Western
Europe was in the 1890s.
And the statistics of the WHO
in the various countries of
Europe support--
and the literature as
well--support this conclusion,
that Asiatic cholera,
after the 1890s,
returns again to Western Europe
only in tiny little outbreaks,
the last of which was 1973.
So, there really isn't
supposedly a history of cholera
in the twentieth century in
Europe.
And it's that that I want to
challenge and to talk with you
about this morning.
Now, as I began--and here we
can start into how the book came
to exist at all.
I, at the time--well,
one, there's this sort of,
as I started doing research on
a very different topic,
I had, in a sense perhaps,
been primed for an interest in
cholera.
I had been primed because I had
lived through an outbreak in
Rome in 1973,
and I had noticed a number of
things that had captured my
attention--
because this was Italy,
this world seventh industrial
power at the time--
and I remember some strange
phenomena.
Being in Rome--the epidemic had
started and found its epicenter
in the city of Naples.
And cars had,
at that time,
license plates that bore the
province of origin of the
vehicle,
and cars in Rome that had
Naples license plates were being
stoned by the citizens of Rome.
It was also true that in the
fish and vegetable markets near
the apartment where I was
living,
that the stalls of the fish and
vegetable sellers were attacked
and overturned by crowds.
So, this seemed something that
captured my imagination very
clearly.
And then the minister of health
went on television and said that
you really didn't need to worry
because all you had to do was to
squeeze--
because the Vibrio,
the bacterium that causes
Asiatic cholera,
is highly susceptible to acid;
so all you have to do is
squeeze a little lemon juice on
your raw mussels,
and then you can quite happily
eat them;
which I wouldn't advise any of
you.
In any case,
it was also true that this
prime minister and the minister
of health visited Naples and the
infectious diseases hospital
there.
And there's an Italian magazine
in which pictures of them
appeared,
and you could see them almost
running down the wards,
as they were visiting the
patients,
and behind them they had their
hands--
you can imagine them
trotting--with this gesture,
which is a gesture to ward off
the evil eye in Italian culture.
So, this seemed rather strange
in the world's seventh
industrial power.
In a sense I had,
then, this subliminal message
that came from an earlier
experience.
But there I was,
a decade or so later,
and my project was--I thought
that I was interested in
political philosophy and social
history,
and I was working on the
disappearance of the European
peasantry under the press of
economic circumstances,
and major transformations in
the countryside,
and the coming of the
commercial revolution in
agriculture,
urbanization and the Industrial
Revolution.
But I began to have my
imagination captured by numbers
of references that I began to
find around the early twentieth
century to cholera in Italy
around 1910.
And that seemed a little
surprising to me,
and it really began--I began to
read more about it.
And it seemed to illustrate how
people's lives were lived,
and their standard of living,
much better than the project
that I originally began with.
And, so, I let this medical
project have a life of its own,
and this is what eventually
became my book.
As I was working more on
cholera, however,
something else came to the
forefront of my attention,
and that was a conflict between
what I read about cholera in the
literature and what I was
beginning to find in my own
research.
The literature said that there
wasn't a major epidemic in the
twentieth century in Europe,
the last major one being in the
1890s.
But I was beginning to find odd
references to some very strange
events,
particularly in the summer of
1911,
and I began to think that
perhaps a very interesting
policy of concealment was taking
place;
that is, an epidemic that was
concealed by the authorities.
And Naples once again was a
very interesting place.
Now, Naples is,
if you're interested in cholera
in the West,
Naples is a very interesting
place because it was the city--
it was the largest city in
Europe in the nineteenth
century,
and it was scourged the most
often by this affliction.
And I'm going to be arguing
that it was scourged also in
times that aren't recorded in
the standard historiography of
the subject,
and in particular in 1911.
It also is an extraordinary
place because it has something
happen that you won't find
elsewhere,
and that is this is a city that
was actually,
after the dreadful epidemic of
1884,
was rebuilt in order to make
the city cholera-proof,
so that it wouldn't return.
So, we see an extraordinary--we
talk about the impact of
infectious diseases,
and here we see a case study of
a place where the city itself is
reconstructed specifically as
result of an epidemic
catastrophe,
in order not to make another
one possible.
We can directly see in bricks
and mortar,
and in the sewers underground
and the buildings above,
and in the layout of the city,
you can see the impact of
cholera and of the idea of
miasma.
Because the miasmatic
interpretation was the one under
which had guided the
reconstruction of the city,
which happened in the wake of
the 1884 catastrophe.
But in 1911,
there was no public record of a
major epidemic.
I had a whiff of the fact that
there was, but I couldn't prove
it.
So, how do you go about
demonstrating an epidemic that
doesn't have a literature?
I thought that the first thing
that would be useful to do would
be to visit Naples,
and in particular to visit the
Naples Cemetery.
The cemetery is a very large
one--you can visit it
yourselves--and it's a very
monumental grand cemetery.
And I went in the middle of the
week with the idea that I would
go to the registry and perhaps
there find records of burials,
and that I would also be able
to see in stone the victims of a
major epidemic.
In other words,
the first idea I had was that
you can't--
in order to prove that there
was an epidemic,
you would have to have a sudden
bulge in mortality in the summer
months of 1911.
And I thought I could
demonstrate that by visiting the
Naples Cemetery,
and if there wasn't a sudden
excess of death in the summer,
then I would know that I was
actually on the wrong trail
entirely and I should abandon my
project.
Well, as I was walking through
the monumental cemetery--
I think it was a Wednesday or a
Thursday--
I suddenly had a car pull up
alongside me,
and the man inside said,
"Get in,
get in."
I don't know exactly how you
would have reacted.
I hesitated;
particularly as it was a
cemetery in which on a Wednesday
and a Thursday I found myself
completely alone,
except for this strange request
that I get in a car with someone
I had never seen before.
Well, it turns out,
as we talked,
that he was the director of the
cemetery, and he had come to
rescue me.
And, so, I did eventually get
in, and he took me out of the
cemetery,
scolding me and telling me that
I was obviously a stranger,
an outsider and a foreigner who
knew nothing,
and that, in fact,
the Naples cemetery is the most
dangerous place you can be in
the city,
which has a long history of
organized crime,
because during the week this
was, in fact,
where the local mafia did its
drug deals,
and that everyone in Naples
knew this except me,
and he was possibly saving my
life by removing me.
It wasn't that I wasn't welcome.
I was welcome to come back on
Saturday and Sunday,
because that's when all the
people of Naples do come to pay
their respects to their
relatives,
and there are flower stalls and
gazillions of people frequenting
the cemetery then,
and the registry office with
the records was also open then.
I also discovered that there
was, in fact--
by reading the newspapers
surrounding the time of my
visit,
that that very summer there was
the--
I was doing a little checking
up, and it turns out that the
rector of the cemetery wasn't
kidding me at all--
that there was a major drug
bust in this very cemetery.
And the way they had done it
was that they had wired the
tombstones,
and in this way they had pulled
off a major move against the
Camorra,
which is the local,
if we like, subset of the
organized crime families in
Italy,
and one of the most important
crime syndicates in the world,
in modern times.
So, that was--that brought me
back on a weekend.
And on the weekend I discovered
that there was,
in fact, a big mortality bulge;
that there were lots of people
who'd been buried in the summer
of 1911,
well in excess of the year
before, 1910,
1909, or the years that were
succeeded,
1912 or 1913.
And there was a book that
registered the deaths and
burials, and there was a huge
bulge in 1911.
So, I knew something had
happened.
And something was interesting,
because one of the features of
the book that's the register of
burials is that they provide the
neighborhood from which the
deceased was resident.
But in this case they,
instead of the usual record of
a neighborhood,
they had the marking Cotugno
Hospital,
was the last place that the
deceased had been.
And the Cotugno Hospital,
then as now,
was the infectious diseases
hospital of the city.
I suddenly knew that there was
this great excess of mortality
in the summer of 1911,
and that the mortality was from
infectious diseases,
because the people had been
buried in vast numbers from the
Cotugno Hospital as their last
port of call.
Then the next thought--and I
think a lot of historical work
is a bit like detective
work--and I found myself playing
a sort of detective role.
So, my next place to visit was
the Cotugno Hospital of
Infectious Diseases.
And I made two findings there
that were confirming me in my
vision of what might have
happened;
that they were--there was in
the library of the hospital,
the hospital itself had
preserved its own records,
patient records.
And after some persistence,
I was allowed to look at
patient records in the hospital,
and found something interesting
and mysterious,
and that was that there were
records of the patient records
through 1908,
'09, '10, and the first half of
1911,
and then suddenly there were no
records at all.
There was a mysterious
disappearance of the records of
the patients of the hospital.
Then I went to the library of
the Infectious Diseases
Hospital,
where there was a second
interesting thing,
which was that the hospital had
its own research journal that it
published,
recording the research findings
of its own physicians,
its own house physicians and
interns and residents.
The result of that was to
discover that for surprise,
surprise, in the summer of 1911
the physicians of the Cotugno
Hospital were doing lots and
lots of research on therapeutics
for Asiatic cholera.
They were experimenting with
giving patients ice,
and lots of other therapeutic
procedures that we'll talk about
in a couple of minutes.
So, I now knew that the
physicians of the Infectious
Diseases Hospital were
enormously preoccupied with
Asiatic cholera.
Then the next place was to go
to the local archives,
where I was told that my idea
was impossible,
there was no such thing;
that there also--the local
records had been moved during
the Second World War out of the
city for safekeeping,
to the Sanctuary of Monte
Cassino, an abbey outside of the
city.
But I think a number of you
have heard of Monte Cassino.
It became a major battle site
in the war,
and so the abbey itself and all
of the archives went up in
flames,
and so all the records of the
city for the period I was
interested in were destroyed.
And I was told that a project
of the kind that I was imagining
was inconceivable and also
couldn't be carried out.
So, what do you do next if you
think there's a major epidemic
and you want to demonstrate its
existence?
The next thing that happened
was that I had the idea that
this was a time,
in 1911, that was the height of
mass emigration of Italians--
that is, I've said that I had
been studying the disappearance
of the European peasantry and
its transformation into workers
or urban dwellers,
and a part of that was the
extraordinary story of Italian
transoceanic migration,
in large part to this country,
but also to Australia and other
places.
So, I thought if there really
was a mass movement--and Naples
is and was then a port.
It was one of Europe's,
along with Hamburg,
major port cities.
And what Naples specialized
in--if Hamburg specialized in
goods and services,
Naples specialized in the
export of people,
and in particular Italian
emigrants to New York City.
There was enormous transoceanic
migration.
I thought well,
if this is true,
and these thousands,
hundreds-of-thousands of
emigrants are moving through the
city of Naples,
and there is a major cholera
epidemic,
and they're arriving at Ellis
Island,
well surely some of them will
have been afflicted with the
disease,
and there would be records
there of that,
at Ellis Island.
Well, as it turns out,
this was true.
There were records.
Cholera did break out on a
series of emigrant-bearing ships
in the summer of 1911,
and people were quarantined for
the disease--
Italians, that is,
who had last been in Naples--
were quarantined for the
disease on Ellis Island.
And indeed, there had been a
number of people who were
released from quarantine and
fell ill on the mainland.
And, so, there are perhaps a
dozen cases of people who fell
sick in New York State and not
on Ellis Island itself.
So, we know that there was
then--there were Italian
emigrants coming to the United
States who were afflicted with
the disease.
This led me to think,
well, I do have a project,
and now the point is to prove
it further.
What can I find out about its
reasons?
What are the politics of
concealment, and so on?
And I was lucky then because I
was interested in a physician
called Leonard Rogers,
who was one of the world's
experts in tropical medicine at
the early years of the twentieth
century.
And it was he who in 1908 made
a major discovery.
In terms of the therapeutics of
Asiatic cholera,
down to 1909,
there was nothing that
physicians could do that was
effective and helpful for their
patients,
and so the case fatality rate
was something like fifty percent
for Asiatic cholera.
In 1908 and 1909,
Leonard Rogers,
who was a British physician
working in India,
had found that he could reduce
the mortality from fifty to
fifteen percent--
the first major advance in
therapeutics--
and he did it,
one by a simple building on
something that had been observed
from the 1830s,
and that is to say that cholera
kills by dehydration.
The bodily fluids flow out of
the rectum and the mouth through
vomiting,
at an extraordinary rate,
so that human beings lose up to
three-quarters of the fluid
portion of their blood serum.
And, so, from the 1830s onward,
one of the therapeutic ideas
was why not simply replace the
fluids?
There were major attempts early
on to get people to drink lots
of liquid.
That doesn't work because you
simply vomit it up.
It has no effect,
except to make the patient
weaker.
So, having discovered that,
there were attempts by
physicians to replace the fluids
intravenously.
The problem early on was that
there was not a knowledge--there
were several problems.
How much liquid do you actually
administer?
And many patients died of heart
failure from an excess of fluid.
It was also a time before the
discovery of the germ theory of
disease,
and so although they were given
drips that had clean water,
it wasn't sterile and patients
died of septicemia.
It was also true that another
discovery,
which was that the
patients--what made people
persist with rehydration is that
this administration of liquid
caused the patients to feel much
better briefly.
For a few hours they seemed to
recover.
They would sit up in their beds
and feel infinitely better.
So something clearly positive
was going on.
But what it was wasn't
understood.
And what happened was that the
administration of fluid was
trying to replace fluid that had
the same salinity as the blood
in the body.
Unfortunately,
that is not retained by
tissues, and it merely pours out
of the body again.
And, so, the patient who had
momentarily,
for a few hours,
felt better,
relapses,
and even the continuing of this
therapeutic attempt had no
positive effect.
Well, Leonard Rogers discovered
in 1909 a number of things.
He measured the amount of fluid
loss.
He used distilled water,
and he made it a
hypertonic--that is,
much more saline than the blood
fluid.
And the result of that was that
it was retained--through
mechanisms that aren't very well
understood, the fluid was
retained.
And, so, Leonard Rogers was
able to save the lives of the
vast majority of the patients he
treated for Asiatic cholera in
India,
and he wanted to--the problem
was this was a time in medical
history when there were racial
ideas of disease,
and it was thought the fact
that he had discovered this with
Indian bodies would have nothing
to do with European bodies.
So, partly for humanitarian
reasons and partly for
scientific reasons,
he was looking for an outbreak
of cholera in the West,
in which he could apply his
therapeutics and demonstrate
their ability to save life,
any human life.
And in 1911,
because he was watching very
closely,
he realized that there was an
epidemic afoot in Italy,
and he sought permission to go
to Naples to demonstrate the
efficacy of his new procedures.
Soon I had Leonard--I was in
contact with Leonard Rogers'
family--
and I had access to his papers,
and his discussion of what
happened to him in the summer of
1911.
Which was that to admit him to
the hospital at Naples to train
physicians in saving lives,
the best available practice,
the only therapy that had any
effect,
would be to admit the presence
of an epidemic.
And, so, he wasn't allowed to
come to mainland Italy.
Instead he was allowed a
two-week visit to Sicily,
where the disease spread as
well.
And the Italian physicians
there called him the
"prince of medicine,"
because they had a survival
rate,
under his direction and his new
rehydration method,
of eighty-five percent,
which was extraordinary by
international standards.
He had discovered the first
effective therapy,
one that is in fact the basis
of present-day therapy for
cholera, which is oral
rehydration.
Leonard Rogers' methods have
been perfected,
but he was the one who found an
effective rehydration system.
Soon we knew,
then, that the state in Italy,
for various reasons,
was preserving a secret and
denying its own citizens the
most effective,
the only effective available
system of care.
So, Leonard Rogers left Italy
in great disappointment,
after only being allowed to
visit the cholera wards in
Sicily,
and was denied by the state the
ability to visit Naples,
which was the epicenter of what
was happening.
The next thing I was able to
discover was that the records
for this epidemic--
there were records,
but they existed not in the
usual places that scholars would
think of to study public health.
The first files on this that I
discovered were in police
records.
And they happened in an odd
way, which was that the prime
minister of Italy ordered the
state police in Italy to deal
with a new offense,
which was sanitary defeatism.
And in order to preserve
silence and not promote sanitary
defeatism,
they began tapping the
telephone lines used by
physicians,
and censoring and opening
physicians' mail.
In the city of Venice in 1911,
there were actually the police
records that demonstrated the
following: which was to say that
the Venice Medical Society
decided quite sensibly in the
summer of 1911 that it would
save lives and enable people to
protect themselves by publishing
pamphlets and distributing them,
about Asiatic cholera and how
you can protect yourself against
it.
And they printed thousands of
these, and wall posters as well,
to put up on the walls of
Venice.
Instead, the Medical Society
was visited by the police,
who confiscated and burned all
of the pamphlets and all of the
wall posters,
and told the physicians of
Venice, the city,
that to propagate health and
sanitary defeatism would be
fatal to their careers.
So, this was all preserved in
the records of the police
regarding the summer of 1911 in
Venice.
The next place that I visited
then was the National Archives
here,
and discovered that Italy had
signed,
in 1903--and this means that
all of the things that I'm
telling you about marked a
violation also of international
law.
Because in 1903 there was a
Paris Sanitary Convention,
which made the full disclosure
of infectious diseases mandatory
for--
Italy and the United States
were both signatories,
along with a series of other
countries.
And the physician who
represented the United States in
1903, a major cholera expert
named Henry Geddings,
was now stationed at Naples
with the U.S.
Embassy, directing the medical
service there.
Why Naples?
Because Naples was the center
of mass emigration from Italy to
the United States,
and there were health
inspections that took place in
the city before departure,
and Henry Geddings was
therefore in charge of
protecting the health of the
United States by heading off
infectious diseases before
people even boarded the ship.
Well, in 1911,
there's an extensive
correspondence,
and a very unhappy
by Henry Geddings and people in
the United States,
including his superiors and his
family,
about his experiences in the
city, where he tried to report
to the United States Government
that there was a major epidemic
of Asiatic cholera.
He found that his life was
threatened in the city of
Naples,
and his superiors in the United
States were not at all
enthusiastic about receiving his
message of what was taking
place,
and so the United States
Government--
you've met Walter Wyman in your
study of the bubonic plague and
the Barbary plague in San
Francisco.
Well, we meet him here again,
actually colluding with the
Italian government in the
suppression of knowledge about
this important major infectious
disease,
against international law that
the United States had actually
signed.
Then there were--in addition to
that,
I then went back to the police
files and discovered that there
were also health statistics that
were coming in to Rome,
reporting events in the Italian
provinces,
and they included statistics
for Asiatic cholera.
But the prefects,
who were the highest authority
for law and order in each
Italian province,
today as then,
were actually sending back,
to help officers in the various
provinces,
the statistics they were
receiving,
saying that,
"These aren't good
statistics;
we don't want them,
send us something better."
And, so, you actually see the
process by which the state
manufactured the health
statistics that were
subsequently published,
and are the basis for the
historiography.
And you can read those
statistics in World Health
Organization reports,
and Italian Government reports,
and in U.S.
Government reports of the
summer of 1911.
Now, why is this true and why
was this so sensitive?
This meant that I needed to go
back in time.
My first idea was to write the
second half of the book,
about concealment.
And I'm introducing that--I
think that's important in our
course--
because we're talking about
various strategies of public
health,
and so far we've looked at
plague regulations and we've
looked at vaccine.
But there's--as you will
remember probably from the SARS
outbreak, that China practiced a
policy of concealment at the
outset.
What I'm trying to say is that
concealment is also a style of
public health policy.
And I think our newspapers
rather misled us in leading us
to believe that this was simply
unique to China,
something very unusual.
I would argue as well that this
is probably something that's
been resorted to a number of
times,
and this epidemic of 1911 is a
good example and a good case
study in which one can find the
actual documents of the
concealment,
and the reasons that it took
place.
Well, why this pressure?
Why does the prime minister of
Italy collude,
and why the United States,
the Surgeon General of the
United States,
also colluded with that?
Indeed, I would tell you
another little anecdote,
which was that Walter Wyman had
a friend who was--
friends, a couple he knew--who
were the parents of young
Johnny,
who just finished his B.A.
degree in 1911--I'm sorry not
here in New Haven,
but rather at that other
unmentionable place in
Cambridge, Mass.
And having finished his degree
in 1911, as a newly minted
Bachelor of Arts,
he was planning a grand tour,
which was going to take in
Italy.
And Italy had--this was the
fiftieth anniversary of Italian
unification, and there was a
major fair with a grand U.S.
pavilion, and Johnny was
planning to visit;
until, that is,
he got a letter from his
friend, the U.S.
Surgeon General,
who wrote to Johnny's parents
that this trip simply wasn't on
in the summer of 1911,
because due to infectious
diseases it wasn't safe to visit
Italy.
At the U.S. Pavilion,
also, the people,
the organizers,
wrote back to Washington,
saying that they were
scandalized and horrified
because American citizens were
not being warned that in fact
there was cholera rampant in
Italy and their health was at
risk,
and there was no knowledge of
this and no coverage of it in
the press.
Well, why would this be
happening?
The first thing is that by this
time there was an enormous
stigma associated with Asiatic
cholera.
Asiatic cholera in Western
Europe and in North America was
supposedly vanquished by the
bulwarks of sanitation and
public health.
Cholera is spread by the
ingestion--in only one
way--which is the ingestion of
food and water contaminated with
fecal matter.
And, so, it really is an
indictment of sanitary
standards.
And therefore one of the
features was a matter of
national pride for Italians not
to admit that there,
in fact, there were these
deficiencies in sanitary
standards,
in a nation that was supposedly
advanced and,
as they would have said,
civilized.
So, part of it then is avoiding
stigma;
this was an important part of
what happened.
But in addition,
there was a patriotism
involved,
because this was the fiftieth
anniversary of Italian
unification,
and the whole world was
descending on Italy;
or so it seemed,
and Italians hoped.
And to destroy the festivities
by putting them off,
by warning the world that
cholera was rampant in Italy at
this time,
would have had enormous
economic repercussions for
tourism,
a major industry.
It also would have had major
repercussions in terms of
Italian pride in canceling the
whole of the celebrations,
a second feature.
Another feature has to do--is
the fact that I've just said,
that the Italian economy and
Italian standards of living were
dependent in part on the export
of people at this time.
These were emigrants who came
to these shores,
and to South America,
and then sent back very
large-scale remittances that
were very important to the
Italian economy.
And what would've happened if
the 1903 Sanitary Convention
terms had been enforced,
in Italy as it should have,
and was legally committed to
doing,
had announced the presence of
Asiatic cholera,
that would have stopped
emigration to these shores and
to South America.
And that was something that
Italians did not want to risk.
And this also could have had
repercussions in terms of civil
disorder.
There was a fear that,
then, too--cholera,
as we'll see,
is much associated with social
tension and disorder,
and that was another fear that
was very much in the minds of
Italians.
But then there's something very
specific,
and that is that--as I said in
the beginning of our talk this
morning--
that Naples had been made
supposedly cholera-proof after
the summer of 1884,
when a catastrophic epidemic
had ravaged the city,
and massive commitment of
funds--Italian but also
Neapolitan and from abroad--
had been devoted to this
rebuilding of the city.
The problem is--I've already
said that Naples was the center
of the Camorra,
of a major criminal syndicate,
and was a place where funds
often disappeared in mysterious
channels.
And one of the features of the
rebuilding project was that the
money largely went into
undisclosed and corrupt
channels.
Here we have a city,
which has supposedly been built
like the Titanic,
just hitting another iceberg
and discovering that,
in fact, the funds that were to
have made it safe have been
misspent.
And there was an opposition to
this municipal government in
Naples, which was using health
as one of the complaints of the
opposition parties.
The opposition parties in
Naples at the time were
republicans, socialists,
anarchists.
And so part of the danger then,
from the standpoint of the
government of the day,
was that to admit this would
lead to a major local scandal,
and would, if you like,
legitimate the complaints and
accusations of a radical
leftwing opposition.
So, a consideration of
political stability was also
part of the calculation.
And this, in fact,
was a motivating factor for the
U.S. Surgeon General and the
U.S. Government;
that here was a friendly
government that was being
lampooned and lambasted by a
radical,
very left-wing opposition,
and it was better to cooperate
then with the government,
the legitimate government,
in the face of this opposition.
Well, this concealment then
went forward,
and it was orchestrated at the
very highest levels.
The press was censored.
Health defeatism actually then
became something that the police
regarded as an infringement and
repressed.
We've seen the way in which
physicians and public health
authorities were censored and
were threatened.
In addition,
it was not discussed in
parliament, and it wasn't even
discussed in the Naples
Municipal Council.
And if you read the
reports--and I read the
discussions of what was being
discussed in Naples in the
summer of 1911--
you see a discussion of the
need for hiring lots and lots of
nurses,
the need for many more doctors.
And you see that they're
importing massive quantities of
snow from the Apennines and the
Alps into the city,
and it's taken to the Cotugno
Hospital.
And there, if you correlate
that with what the physicians
were doing,
they were giving ice to cholera
patients on the ward to deal
with the tremendous thirst that
they had,
and to replace,
they hoped, some of the fluid
that they were losing through
the course of the disease.
So, that was all--this
conspiracy then is not a casual
one.
It's organized from the top
down, and is a very major and
well-organized plot to conceal
the existence of this epidemic.
In addition then,
what were the consequences of
concealment?
I want to argue
that--throughout this
course--that public health is
dependent on accurate and timely
information.
We'll see that today,
in that a major feature of
public health policies is
surveillance and monitoring,
and the availability of
information,
nationally and internationally,
is vital to contain and prevent
pandemic afflictions.
So, one of the features--and I
think 1911 is a good example of
what happens if you don't
provide information.
A first thing that happened was
that this disease spread through
many provinces of Italy.
It was not contained
domestically.
Fortunately,
it did not spread to these
shores and to Argentina and to
other places where large numbers
of Italians went.
But I think that was no thanks
to the Italian government,
it had to do with serendipity
and good luck.
What I could say was that the
Italian government,
with the collusion of the U.S.
government, was placing the
health of this country,
and the health of Argentina in
particular, at risk.
It was placing at risk the
health also of international
visitors to Italy,
tourists and people who came to
see the celebrations of 1911.
And one of the truly
unfortunate parts of the
concealment effects is that it
led to thousands of deaths of
Italians.
Because the patients on the
wards of the Cotugno Hospital,
and elsewhere in Italy,
were systematically denied what
was then the best available
international practice,
which is the administration of
rehydration therapy,
as developed by Leonard Rogers,
and Italian doctors weren't
allowed to know that this was
the state-of-the-art and the way
in which it was possible to save
Italian lives,
reducing mortality from fifty
to fifteen percent,
or something like that.
If you look at the Cotugno
ward, what were the physicians
doing instead?
Well, instead,
because cholera patients become
tremendously cold and look as
though they've been cadaverized,
they were immersing cholera
patients in hot tubs.
Because for the same way as
their energy was failing,
they were administering them
stimulants, caffeine.
And there were various
experiments with other things
that were meant--
because there wasn't a therapy
that was known to work,
there were lots of experimental
therapies that were being tried.
Strychnine, which you know
better as rat poison,
was also administered to
cholera patients,
in an attempt to revive their
energy and their flagging
health.
Also there were attempts at
rehydration therapy.
But this took the form that was
now outdated,
after 1908, of trying to get
the patients to suck on ice,
or to drink,
or to be injected with isotonic
saline solutions;
that is, of the same content of
salt, same salinity as the
blood, which by 1908,
through a century of
experience, was known to be
entirely useless.
And these were the kinds of
therapies that were being
practiced, plus simply
supportive nursing care.
And as I said,
the hospital was recruiting
very large numbers of nurses.
So, nursing care and various
experimental and sometimes
heroic interventions that led to
a very high mortality rate,
when in fact it was possible to
save about eighty-five percent
of patients.
Well, I've run out of time,
and so I'll just say then that
this is how this particular book
came to be.
And I ended up writing,
adding on, that in order to
understand 1911,
it was absolutely crucial to
see 1884 and the steps that had
been taken,
unfortunately not so
successfully,
to make Naples cholera-proof by
the early twentieth century,
when sadly it wasn't.
And I think there's a story
there of concealment as a public
health policy that I wanted to
alert you to as yet another
style of public health,
and one that has very--it's not
good for your health--
and has very dire consequences.